Коли останній весняний сніг перетворюється на багнюку, пересуватися все складніше.
Цей нетиповий для Донбасу ліс став прихистком для українських військових.
Говорити тут треба тихо, тому що російські позиції розташовані лише за кілька сотень метрів звідси.
Іван і його друг тримають передову позицію. Без листя на деревах вони - як на долоні.
Та принаймні можуть бачити, коли наближаються російські підрозділи.
Зовсім скоро природа надасть укриття і їм, і противнику.
Найважче, коли тихо. Бо тоді можуть іти.
Тоді більше уваги. Коли вони накривають, впевнений, що вони неблизько.
А коли тихо, саме таке, що можуть підповзти.
Іван пробуде тут два дні і дві ночі. Здається, недовго, втім треба постійно бути насторожі.
Дві години сну - дві години чергування. Сил дають грілки для рук та енергетичні напої.
Відпочинок - у "чотиризірковому" окопі.
Це "четвірка", там ще "трієчка" в процесі будівництва позаду вас.
У перший день, як тільки ми заступили першого разу сюди, по нас 120-та міна працювала, десь метрів 20-30.
Такі звуки і хвиля досить гучні.
Як і тисячі українських військових, до повномасштабного вторгнення Іван ніколи не тримав у руках зброю.
Втім, новачкам доводиться швидко вчитися.
Ми зазвичай із товаришами віджартовуємося. Тут таке рятує.
На негативі довго не протягнеш.
Я казав: я дзвонив мамі і просив, щоб вона мене звідси забирала.
Ну, то ми так жартуємо.
Це головне укриття - печера, вибита у схилі. Всередині тепло, сухо і відносно безпечно.
Після постійного стресу тут можна перевести подих і відволіктися.
У кожного з нас є малюнок чи малюнки. Надсилають. Ми ці малюнки не викидаємо, нікуди не діваємо.
Вони зберігаються в нас. Так вони і носяться з перших днів.
Цей малюнок з Німеччини передавали.
Підписано лист: "Дякуємо за те, що захищаєте нас. Сподіваємося на повернення".
Дружина вагітна. Буквально з березня місяця, на початку війни.
Я став батьком уже на війні безпосередньо.
Якраз так пощастило, що мене відпустили, коли народився.
І то народився - я не був у пологовому, а якраз у дорозі був з полігону в лікарню.
Військові часто кажуть: воюють, аби цього не довелося робити їхнім дітям.
Ніхто не вірить у те, що Росія піде на чесні перемовини.
На цьому бронетранспортері з поля бою вивозять поранених.
У ньому так трясе, що солдати жартують: поки доїдеш, заробиш нові поранення.
Ми в режимі 24 на 7 приймаємо виклики.
Як "швидка допомога", тільки трошки така… незвична "швидка".
З ризиком, що тебе можуть вбити.
Ось, наприклад, вчора поруч із нами було обстріляне розташування військ.
Там близько 13 поранених і двоє загиблих.
Психоемоційний стан людей дуже складний.
Тарас пояснює: військових, які зазнали сильних психологічних травм, евакуюють.
Але більшості доводиться триматися. Декому допомагають таблетки.
У цивільному житті Тарас працював невропатологом, тож знається на медикаментах.
Це все антидепресанти й ліки проти тривожності.
Це я зібрав і за необхідністю зараз усім, хто потребує, даю.
Вони матимуть лише симптоматичний ефект, бо якщо ми говоримо про лікування тривожного синдрому,
депресії, стресових розладів, то основне лікування - мінімізація травмуючих психоемоційних факторів.
Під час війни це апріорі неможливо. Тому активно користуємося і всім радимо.
У постійному стресі не лише пацієнти, а й самі медики.
Тарас зізнається, що сам теж почав приймати антидепресанти.
За понад рік війни він був зі своєю родиною лише кілька днів.
Усі, кого ви бачили зараз, це цивільні люди. Не професійні військові.
Це все мобілізовані. Вважайте, 20 відсотків у нас - професійні контрактні військовослужбовці.
Усе інше - мобілізовані. Це вихід. Усе нормально.
Більш досвідченим військовим теж нелегко.
У минулому юрист, Олексій уже пенсіонером пішов служити в АТО.
Після кількох років відпочинку - нове російське вторгнення.
Сил немає вже ані фізичних, ані моральних.
Мені шостий десяток - усі болячки, які тільки можна, повилазили назовні.
А теж за рік скільки я перетягав поранених на руках.
Спина вже… болить так, що капець.
Поки в багатьох українських містах вирує мирне життя, Олексій зізнається: військовим складно не лише в бою, а й у тилу.
Ось збираємося, приїхала наша команда.
Ми сядемо - жартуємо, ми один одного розуміємо з пів слова, нам комфортно абсолютно.
Ти виходиш до цивільних людей і розумієш, що ми різними мовами розмовляємо, зовсім.
Їхні жарти мені здаються пласкими і дратують мене.
Мої слова не доходять до них. І ось ця відстань усе збільшується.
На моєму прикладі: мене дружина десять днів за руку водила, щоб я ніде не вліз.
Дратують оті морди, які вдвічі молодші за мене, ховаються за броню,
зате викладають фотки на природі. Це дратує, правда дратує.
Зрозуміти, що таке війна, може лише той, хто побував на ній сам або відправив близьку людину, з досвіду каже Олексій.
Його син нині теж на передовій.